one plating action llama slate Disney
disaster news submitted by Joel Somalian
water filter a video of a Disneyland
brawl between a family went viral
oh that one yeah [__] that [__] was
crazy it look like drama
Joe how have you not been on this I'm
bummed because I was at Disney a week
before it he didn't see same here
no yeah I didn't see it this is like CW
[__] dude there's like 20 people just
been able I can give you the breakdown
cuz I watched this video like three
million times so all the views were you
yes I get to see it here we go the first
time this is sickening dude this shows
nuts oh my god a baby comes out baby
comes out
why does it look like trash that he's
like angry Busta Rhymes dude the setting
is perfect goes there like oh thank god
not the musician even the guy with the
guitars coming out I hate this this
video so many times you're down as
stressful with all the squiggly
architecture I mean you could step on
different things and it makes different
sounds hmm
where's what happened from my my
recollection of please I will tell you
in the beginning red shirt and white
shirt lady yeah what red shirt white
shirt lady it appears that they are
sibling quit shirt got upset with white
shirt because he said something about
don't disrespect my daughter my girl or
some [__] I don't know what happened but
that happened there in the beginning so
white shirt spits in red shirts face and
then that's when guy white shirt which
seems to be the girl white shirts man
starts to get
fight with red shirt because he
disrespected his lady so then that's
when like the whole altercation happened
between white shirt girl and red shirt
guy so then that's happening this is
what this is the same family this is all
the things same family yeah then they're
fighting that's when brown shirt girl
and the black shirt girl with the
backpack it seems like the black shirt
girl with the backpack is is related to
red shirt and white shirt girl and so
then when the brown shirt girl comes up
she is the girl of the red shirt guy so
then she's like hold on hold on hold on
hold on the one that he was beating at
the end I'll tell you how he got there
the white shirt guy popped her that's in
the beginning we're going in order yeah
so then when she goes hold on hold on
hold on
that's when white shirt just to like
shut her up he goes like he's looking at
red shirt like that's what they deal
with their [__] problems so then
because white shirt hits red shirts girl
which is the brown shirt girl red shirt
starts attacking white shirt again and
like beating his ass and then black pack
sister which I'm assuming of the red
shirt she gets involved and then that's
when the mom with the striped shirt in
the wheelchair comes in tries to
separate yeah so then she comes in and
like everyone is in this rumble and
during that rumble can you buy tickets
to their family reunion no I will never
support that it's so gross so then
during that rumble that's when red shirt
white shirt guy are into it and then
brown shirt and white shirt girl are
into it and the moms trying to separate
the them too and then that's when
backpacked chick comes in tries to
separate those two chicks so then now
backpack chick is yelling at brown shirt
girl like what the [__] you don't be
hitting my sister I'm assuming and then
white shirt girl grabs the hair a brown
shirt girl and somehow the mom was
standing there so the moms hair all
oh so then that's when brownshirt girl
accidentally was like hit the mom
because she's trying to hit the sister
and then they get into this big ol thing
that's when the mom falls to the ground
and then that's when brownshirt comes
over to the mom is like oh my god like
get up I'm so sorry I didn't mean to hit
you and like she's apologizing there and
then red shirt guy comes over tries to
help the mom and then that's when red
shirt starts slapping the white shirt
girl and so like you see it is but like
you said get the [__] out of my house
I'm getting stressed so the white shirt
girl falls to the ground and then
backpack girl comes over to us to health
and mom brown shirt gives the moms a
backpack girl and she's like here at
help her help her get to the wheelchair
and so she's trying to help her and then
when backpack girl sees red shirt guy
she's like she [__] hit her talking
about brown shirt girl so then she
instigate the red shirt guy to punch his
own girl he's like you [__] hit my
mama and he's just like pop up and then
so he started beating her ass Wow
and that's when everyone split everybody
apart so if you guys want to act it out
at home we just did all the lines for
you [__] the entire transcript is
just talk don't you I knew what happened
yeah no really it's cool it was a little
interesting it was like a play-by-play
it was like I was listening to sports
radio yeah and then it was like the red
team's [__] about the big Martin you
know it was like they dominated the the
upturned 1950s when um when the guy like
at the end with red shirt and brown
shirt when he started beating her ass
like crazy that's when this dude comes
up and he's the one that's getting a lot
of Fame out of this story because is the
guy with the hair right the Mexican guy
he's the mexican guy with the hat he's
he's actually an El Paso high school
football coach his name's Jason he's the
one that's getting a lot of praise
because they're like media saying like
no one stepped in like you stepped in
but but he didn't stop [__] after I
watched the video so many times there
are some many other people that said
they tried yeah it was an Asian guy with
a guitar there was a you know like the
yeah there was a chaste guy but I think
he was the one that actually like
apprehend him and pulled him to the
ground that stopped it he was in the
middle of it other people were like
corral like I said he's actually the one
in I don't know who he is but he was the
red backpack guy he jumps on the back of
red shirt and chokes him and like that's
how he was able or Jason was able and
with this other guy was able to like
move them away because the red backpack
guy I would have give him the credit for
stopping everything but but he didn't
get camera time the way he was like I
don't want to be just give me a
knowledge I would have been mad so the
guy the red shirt guy he was like what
the [__] Toby [__] you you look like you
would that keep me extra anonymous yeah
however like me it looked like there was
this one guy who was only hitting women
the red shirt guy yeah it was funny
because it looked like the two guys were
trying to fight each other and they were
just punching women you push my girl I
punch your girl look this is my own
girlfriend oh [__] I'm sorry baby [__]
the girls more than they [__] each other
I've seen the beginning of fight like
hold my daughter away like this [__]
happens a lot in that [__] oh yeah oh
yeah boys face no right oh okay we doing
this again it was like I'm gonna stop
this adjust me me was in the very
beginning they're in a circle and I
couldn't see the stroller in the middle
so they were like [__] talking [__]
with my kid on top of the baby and I
know that all right I did they pull the
stroller I'm like what the [__] there's
two babies there
well at least they have morals they
didn't punch the baby and I'll [__] you
and then push the baby - I know and
they're not sexist at all yeah because
if you're willing to punch a man you
should be willing to punch a woman as
well I've always believed that little
baby they're like this little kids a
little toddler that was just like he was
in the middle of it I'm so glad he
didn't get hurt we learned all of that a
stranger exchange later you could see
her like scoop him up and take you in a
safety so I'm like that's so nice good
job
isn't that the most slowest fight you've
ever seen so that is a very slow fight
it took about three minutes fish four
minutes for security to finally get
there I'm surprised because I thought
Disneyland was like a casino with crazy
security and like could you just never
see them and like they all dress like
that and shoot the camera here and they
have the earpiece like that no I thought
they had a lot of like like surveillance
and special like pathways and alleyways
cuz then dancers also also use it when
they do the parade yeah so I thought
like you'll see like Mickey Mouse
security just boys down but really out
of the way you have a toontown I thought
we're gonna hear Goofy's music plan and
he's gonna come in start [__] with
hear the music towards the end of this
video so happy you like this is one of
the employees the 2-ton employees just
sitting there going like oh my god but
yeah like a bright a shirt on yeah I
don't know after all this that no
charges repressed like what chakras
within the same family that's yeah but
OC prosecutors that are reviewing the
family brawl video they are they're
saying that there's gonna seek some
justice here
I wonder if Neil and yeah the whole
family you get banned from Disney for
this year they need to go to Disney
Court it's like yeah okay Nikki Mike you
like Mickey like needs to serve their
daddy
ended up tweeting out yesterday the
Anaheim Police Department presented the
case from Disneyland to this person for
review and prosecution if you are or if
you know a victim of domestic violence
seek help yes the red shirt guy was just
like I'm mad here punch you you may me
now imma punch you you made me map some
I'll punch you to think they're real
only able to see like like right here
like for as soon as he found out that
she acts as a man thing sorry Oh cuz
then the the brown shirt girl was
telling him like they were beating you
up like I was trying to back you up I
accidentally hit your mom in the
in the middle of that here just like but
you hit my mom you [__] hit my mom
like yeah there's some ghetto ass
behavior I grew up watching [__] like
this so it's [__] hate it dude
it's such a waste of energy because they
could have been like with all that
energy that could have been in Star Wars
land punch in Star Wars man yeah the
violence word count much nicer story
[Music]